hey everyone i'm abby Sharpe from Abby's
kitchen in today's video I'm going to be
talking about a highly requested
youtuber San Louie so before we get into
this I want to of course remind you that
this video is for entertainment purposes
only and is not intended to prescribe or
diagnose so you should definitely always
speak to your doctor and a dietician
about an eating routine that is best
suited to you ok so let's get into this
now son is a 24 year old former
Victoria's Secret model who's created a
YouTube channel to share her personal
health journey fitness routines what she
eats as a model and otherwise fabulous
young model life now instead of
reviewing only one what eight and day
video I'm going to review three videos
to make sure that I'm covering a variety
of meals I mean my goal here with these
what ain't no Dave reviews has always
been to use them as opportunities to
debunk misinformation promote balance
and celebrate a healthy relationship
with food but I sometimes worry that
occasionally kind of gets lost so I want
to make sure that I'm bringing that back
as best as I can so I'll be reviewing a
variety of meals from different videos
so I can give you feedback on the
philosophy and overall balance and also
spend less time kind of nitpicking diet
stuff which really isn't my style
and then more time discussing some of
the problematic claims and reasons that
I like the channel in general or don't
okay so let's dive in let's take a look
at one of her breakfast I do change up
my kind of smoothie sometimes I go for
my veggies fruit today I'm going to make
another crease and the base is going to
be some primitive Spanish I'm adding
some frozen broccoli and then we're
going to add 1 TSP of flexi if I want to
have a little bit of a lighter smoothie
what I do I use half milk and then I use
half water
have protein and I just got this one on
Amazon it has some new flavor
okay so here's the thing about protein
powder I believe that they are a super
convenient easy way to sneak in extra
protein without really contributing a
whole lot of flavor but in the case of
Sens portion for this hemp protein
powder I'm not that sure what the point
is so for the brand that Sam is using a
four tablespoon serving provides 15
grams of protein this means for the 1
tablespoon that she used she's getting
about three point seven five grams of
protein I mean she's better off just
like adding more flax or something so
she wouldn't have to bust out a whole
other container now while I love the
fact that she's using a plant-based
protein powder it may be beneficial to
either
I don't know measure out a larger
serving so she can actually reap some of
the benefits or perhaps use a different
protein powder like pea protein which
actually has around 20 to 25 grams of
protein per scoop otherwise I mean it's
a solid smoothie I like that there's fat
in it and veggies for the fiber I just
feel like if you're feeling like you
need a source of protein just like go
for it okay so let's take a look at
video number two detox they mean it
means I eat very very clean with very
wholesome foods barely any processed
foods and before I'm going to start this
video I just want to tell you guys as
well that this is not how I eat every
day this is more how I eat like when I
feel when I travelled a lot or when I
party the laws or when I have a lot of
like holidays and I kind of want to like
eat very clean and like refresh my body
sister now before I start this one I
realize like she said that this isn't
every day for her however it does bring
value to see a day like this in
comparison to some of her other days you
guys know I am NOT
a fan of this cleanse yourself rhetoric
I mean even if you have been traveling
and drinking a lot your body still
deserves to eat but having said that
let's take a look-see at what she is
eating and considers a detox so the
reason why to drink lemon juice early
first thing in the morning is it just
really helps with your digestive jab
justice system and some people put it in
like hot water I don't personally really
love it but you can do that as well also
what I'm going to start with is drink a
lot of water
I almost drink like one of these bottles
like in the morning and especially when
I'm detoxing I drink so so so much water
to like flush everything up why does
every youtuber feel the need to
perpetuate this misinformation sure
lemon water or tea may be more exciting
than plain water but it won't increase
your digestion of your food I mean our
stomach is very very acidic and adding a
little bit of acid or like lemon juice
isn't gonna change a whole lot so let's
put this pH diet myth to bed okay what's
next take a much without like any milk
but I'm gonna drink a little green tea I
am going to bring my package to the
office and get a little bit of work done
and then I will see you guys for
breakfast for breakfast we're going to
make a hydrating and detoxifying
smoothie we start with a bunch of frozen
kill some frozen spinach and frozen
pineapple the ginger really helps to
detox the body and will give the
smoothie a very fresh taste then I add
one and a half cup of coconut water okay
let's do this this breakfast is leaving
a lot to be desired obviously it's
really low in calories without much
protein or even that much fat or carbs I
mean it's a lot of just vegetables now I
fully get that after a big night of
eating or drinking as soon as your body
is just not wanting a big heavy meal I
mean that is totally common
not really the issue here the issue is
that she's professing this meal that
she's trying to detox and that is why
she's choosing these low-calorie foods
and that is a little bit where I'm
turned off let's hope that video number
three is a little bit better side note
ginger is delicious
and it has a lot of health properties
but it does not inherently detox your
body next beat I'm always trying to put
superfood say my food such an easy way
to see and the rest I'm going to score
you can use any other like clam milk
like almond milk cashew milk but I find
ok so this is a solid portion and a very
pretty breakfast I mean we do know that
a higher protein breakfast will keep you
satiated longer and it's always nice to
see protein evenly distributed
throughout the day for blood sugar
purposes but if she's a car person in
the morning then that's cool with me I
mean thankfully the fiber in the fruit
the cacao nibs and the chia seeds will
help with that blood sugar regulation a
bit but still I would say most people
would be pretty hungry shortly after a
meal like this so let me give you my
overall thoughts on her breakfast Sam
clearly likes her liquid breakfast and
while it's not something I recommend
people have every single day if she
enjoys it and it works for her it works
for me my biggest concern is that
they're practically all carbs and
there's not a lot of protein going on
here research does suggest that having a
protein rich meal in the morning can
help improve satiety and help you feel
less hungry later on in the morning
since protein helps to increase peptide
YY levels which is a hormone that helps
keep your hunger levels at bay if she
feels good and this holds her for a
while then amazing but for most people
my recommendation for a satisfying
breakfast would maybe be to add some
more protein rich foods to her smoothie
so things like nut butter more hemp
seeds soy milk which is higher in
protein than the oat milk Greek yogurt
if you're not vegan silken tofu or a
higher protein a protein powder like pea
protein let's take a look at her lunches
now
appetit I feel they're always like two
people in there for people who have a
bow like this completely you're not mess
it up and mix it up and then you have
people who like eat it nicely
bye-bye I think I'm gonna eat this bite
by bite and like so this bowl looks
seriously delish almost too pretty to
eat really she's got a nice combination
of fiber from all of the veggies and the
fruit in there she's got protein from
tofu and beans as well as healthy fats
in the oil the tahini and the hemp seeds
and of course that big avocado I am
happy to see her step up her protein
game at lunch
even if ideally we would want to see
this spread out a little bit more
throughout the day okay let's take a
look at her detox day oh I'm scared boil
some water and add the broccolini in
here I grab a little Bowl and add 4
spoons of olive oil and I add 1
tablespoon 1 teaspoon of turmeric a
pinch of salt and you need to add pepper
to boost the turmeric this step is very
important because the kill will be soft
and much easier and tastier to digest
[Music]
okay so this salad sounds delicious like
maybe I was like a side salad but again
it's feeling a little restrictive in
light of the whole detox thing I don't
know I'm just feeling a lot of goop
happening right now
goop inspiration and I'm not loving it
so apparently detox means pretty much
just eating vegetables but protein
provides so much nutrition to the body
that it's it's really important even on
days that you're detoxing I mean
whatever that means the protein is going
to help keep you satiated and energized
and help stabilize your blood Sugar's
throughout the afternoon also eating
super low calorie and clean in response
to overeating and partying too hard
often actually backfires the next day
you often feel so deprived you bounce
right back to the opposite end to
overeat again and the cycle just
continues on not loving this day I will
say that she was totally right when she
said that you need to add some black
pepper to boost the absorption of
tumeric so this is actually true this
there's a compound in pepper called
pepper in which helps to increase the
absorption of turmeric which is
otherwise poorly absorbed into the body
one claim that she did make that was
only partially true is the green or the
salad the more antioxidants it has now
green vegetables are super high in
antioxidants but other colored veggies
are really high as well and we can't get
all of the powerful antioxidants our
body craves just from greens for example
orange foods provide carotenoids red
gives lycopene and dark blue and purple
give anthocyanins these are all plant
pigments with really powerful
antioxidant properties that pack a
really big punch of real nutrition so
you don't want to kind of scare away or
shy away from eating other kind of
colorful foods just because you're
trying to get in your antioxidant rich
greens let's look at lunch number three
then I'm going to add some pumpkin seeds
and I'm going to add some fresh mint or
fresh coriander this lunch looks so
freakin good love that Sam added
lentils and a hard-boiled egg for some
protein the avocado obviously gives
those healthy fats and again lots of
beautiful vegetables overall this lunch
provides a good source of carbs fat
fiber and protein that will no doubt
keep her satisfied for hours looks
awesome okay so let me know give you my
overall thoughts on lunch overall I
think she's getting plenty of veggies
into her lunches which of course is
important for vitamins minerals and
fiber what's more she uses excellent
sources of healthy fats like avocado and
olive oil and it's also really nice to
see that at least on detox days she's
not afraid of oils and fat I will say
that of course her lunches on day one
and day three were much better than on
the cleanse day because they included
some kind of source of protein so if
you're looking for some mealtime
inspiration I recommend looking towards
those days now let's look at those
dinners
awesome so this looks really really good
and I would totally crush that right now
I love curry and it's awesome that she
does in this in this video talk about
how she makes extra for the next day and
I also love that she uses the rice
cooker to take a little bit of the lake
work out of the cooking again the
simpler we can really make things for
ourselves the much easier it feels to
eat really healthy nourishing foods but
honestly I do think this is a really
well-rounded and delicious meal the
brown rice gives us those slow digesting
carbs and fiber it's got tons of veggies
and fats and a good source of protein
from the chicken she also uses some
really awesome spices to make the dish
look and tastes so so amazing and I also
I love pineapple in my rice too so I
definitely want this so tea oat milk in
there it is just like chai tea oh okay
just like finishing off her dinner with
something sweet totally my style I also
love the spices in chai tea and I think
the combination of chai tea and
chocolate is pretty awesome so this I
can get on board with let's take a look
at video number two where I have a
feeling we won't see chocolate the onion
carrot and one cup of celery this is
more or less three sticks when the
onions are soft and brown you're going
to add the garlic two cups of cubed
butternut squash and the sweet potato
and three babies
in the last five minutes I add some
extra kale and wait until it's soft and
then the soup is ready what are you
eating okay so still a super light meal
but I would say a lot better than some
of the previous detox options so here we
see at least some chickpeas and quinoa
which provides some plant-based protein
and carbs the butternut squash the sweet
potato also gives some slow digesting
carbs and there's lots of really great
vegetables in here which is great to see
again I get that some days you just
don't feel like big heavy meals and your
digestion maybe feels a little bit
sluggish or off that's cool do what you
got to do but I just don't want people
thinking that they need to purposefully
restrict themselves or detox all day if
their body actually wants full meals
let's take a look at video number three
you
okay I just need to stop right there
because there's so many missteps with
the pasta and to start me crazy one
bigger pot for that pasta we need to
give it some room to bloom so to speak
it needs more water than what you're
giving it right there
- don't rinse your pasta before you put
it into the sauce because you're rinsing
off some of the surface starch which
helps the sauce stick to the pasta and
also you're rinsing off any flavor that
you may be added by like salting the
water so just oh don't do that okay
continue okay okay so I'm a pasta lover
and I do love this dish it just goes to
show that just because you want to eat
more plant-based I mean with the
exception of the Parmesan cheese it
doesn't mean you can't enjoy foods that
you've always loved I will say that
cashew sauces can be very pricey
depending on the cost of cashews in your
region so just keep that in mind
however it's awesome to see that she's
trying out different kinds of noodles
and experimenting with different kinds
of flavors so chickpea pastas like the
one that she's using here I love them
they're high in fiber in protein so it's
actually something that I cook a lot in
my home especially for my carb loving
kid if this was my dish I don't know I
probably would throw in like a can of
chickpeas or maybe some more vegetables
but it looks like a really satisfying
delicious beautiful looking meal okay so
my overall thoughts on her dinners is
that they seem like the most substantial
meals of the day I'm seeing a little bit
more protein a little bit more fiber a
little bit more carbs and all of the
recipes look really enjoyable and
relatively easy and definitely like
something that I personally would want
to eat so now let's talk about the
overall picture here number one are
these meals balanced so Sam seems like a
really great cook with
super mouth-watering meals she has a
fantastic grasp of spices and really
knows how to make dishes look flavorful
and enjoyable I appreciate that
unlike a lot of youtubers it doesn't
seem like she's specifically cutting out
any major food groups so I am seeing a
lot of different foods throughout her
days and while her detox day was
definitely low in calories and not sling
I am personally jazzed to see day one
and day three averaged around 2,000
calories which seems like a really
reasonable place for her
so for those of you guys who are
thinking that Victoria's Secret models
must starve themselves I think that this
video would suggest that it's not
necessarily the case if we want to chat
about some general nutrition
recommendations that I kind of brought
up in this video I would say again that
most people do benefit from spreading
their protein out throughout the day but
in general I do think there's some
balanced options in the mix so if a
higher carb breakfast works for her it
works for me now is Sen missing out on
any specific nutrients again I would say
she probably could up the protein a
little bit even though I am happy to see
them coming predominantly from
plant-based sources insurance she's
getting enough protein will definitely
help her feel fuller longer support her
during her busy busy day and help with
muscle building and maintenance and just
her overall health in general also I
don't see a lot of omega-3 fatty acids
in our diet which again are extremely
important for heart health brain health
and many other body functions although
some nuts and seeds are good sources of
omega-3s the omega-3s that they're rich
in are the ala s and they're not very
high in EPA and DHA which have been
shown to have the best benefits for our
body
unfortunately ala omega-3s are not
converted very well to EPA and DHA in
the body so we really need to get these
nutrients from our diet so looking at
things like fatty fish eggs some algae
these are common options as well as
taking a supplement I'm also not sure
what her supplement regime looks like as
she doesn't really mention it but that
would be my major recommendation for her
now am i seeing any problematic claims
or assumptions
okay so I know working as a Victoria's
Secret model comes with some unrealistic
body standards but this whole detox day
really has me a little concerned and
disappointed yes I get that the modeling
world is a hot spot for diet culture so
I can only imagine how normal this
language is but we really need to get
away from the detox focus our bodies are
incredibly intuitive and can handle the
occasional weekend bender or a few long
days without needing to undo the damage
with a overly restrictive diet by
fueling our bodies with wholesome
nutrient-dense calories we're giving it
all it needs to do its job again I know
that her detox day wasn't a normal day
but that video really showed some wrong
messages about nutrition and how our
bodies work for example if you really
enjoy drinking pure lemon juice that is
totally cool I mean your teeth might not
feel so great but a simple cup of water
and like a nourishing meal will
kick-start your digestion
perfectly fine okay so now let's talk
about so my favorite two takeaways from
Stan's channel number one she doesn't
cut out any specific food groups I love
the fact that Sam doesn't identify with
any specific type of eating style I mean
some days she eats fully plant-based and
some days she doesn't although sometimes
she makes videos on dairy-free or
gluten-free foods she doesn't seem to
follow any specific way of eating
religiously she embraces all types of
foods and I can totally get on board
with that number two she seems more
interested in paying attention to
nutrients not calories so in two of
these videos she does mention the
calorie count of her meals and that's
because of course she's being sponsored
by a calorie counting app but she does
mention that she uses the app
specifically for tracking nutrients to
make sure she's getting everything in
and doesn't really pay attention to the
calories per se so for example in one
video she expresses focusing on calories
doesn't really tell us the whole picture
and that for example a nutrient-dense
salad may have 400 to 500 calories but a
bag of chips may only have 150 calories
obviously the salad to be a better
choice
she mentions that but if you only focus
on the calories alone then you miss out
on so much good
fueling nutrition I mean honestly I am
still not totally sure if the
partnership with the calorie tracking
app is like perfectly aligned if this is
her stance but honestly that is her
brand decision to make not mine but I'm
at least happy to hear that she's more
interested in getting enough nutrition
not just cutting calories and finally
her recipes are produce packed
nutrient-dense and really delicious
looking san really knows her way around
the kitchen and eats a ton of beautiful
colorful vegetables it's clear that she
always is looking for ways to make her
meals both delicious and nutritious and
shows her audience that eating healthy
foods does not need to be boring or
complicated at all overall I think that
Sam has a great personality and seems to
have a pretty good relationship with
food even if her choice and sponsorships
is a little confusing although I would
totally ditch the detox days some of the
questionable claims here and maybe bump
up her protein at breakfast a bit I
think the sound is at least sharing a
variety of tasty looking recipes but
even I would really want to try out
myself so folks that is all for today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with any youtubers that you want me to
review subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]